Now the other thing is that in a resegmented market and again we use Southwest
as a low-cost entry or whole foods as a unique niche supplier via positioning
and what you really want to start asking is what factors can you eliminate that your industry
has long competed on or what can you reduce below the industry standard
or raise above the industry standard or what can be created that the industry has never offered?
Now what's interesting is if you look at the chasm between your early adopters,
your early evangelists and the mainstream market in a resegmented market
this is what Moore was kind of talking about called the chasm.
There really is a gap between what these people want and a gap between their needs.
And if you're not careful your sales curve well it would start looking like this over here
and actually might collapse until the mainstream adopts.
So let's take a look at what a sales curve might look like in a resegmented market.
And it's a complex sales growth chart because in the first couple of years
you're just kind of getting the spillover of people who kind of think you're just
a competitor in the existing market and your sales will kind of toddle along until if you're correct
and you were right about that niche or low-cost segmentation
you will start seeing an exponential increase in sales.
And if you're wrong, well you'll just kind of be one of the many competitors
in an existing market.